[Music]
hello happy Tuesday
we're a little late it's my fault as per
usual but we're gonna check out call
duty black out or call of duty black ops
four black out its new map Alcatraz
are you Nicolas Cage welcome to the rock
oh so you're Sean Connery and I'm
Nicolas Cage yeah I make sounds great
I'm gonna have to like touch mine
alright let's do this thing Rob that's
Rob I'm Eric if you didn't know we're
gonna try to do this thing it's a waste
smaller map it's like 1 to 40 players
and only water are available right any
quads currently so we'll see how this
goes try to get a W here try can I get
just on my own headphones yeah it's just
a little more gameplay yeah and you
could probably turn you turn you down a
little bit but I think how's that that
sounds pretty good ok now I'm feeling it
because I got a swap off to this thingy
yo this is our this is our home turf I
have not played blackout since the the
first like time it kind of came out yeah
but we are in SF we're in San Fran we
got to get the Dobies here we got the
home field advantage
Aaron one would hope how do you play
this game again we'll see what's up
Christian Phillips what's up oh well
staging area try to learn the map oh I'm
in the water oh can you swim in the
water what if you just like hung out in
the water dog by the pole will get you
this just inverted I always get confused
oh I think Aaron plays inversion
inverted I thought you liked inverted
what No
hi kick this sorry guys do one more
thing sensitivity I like mine I'm a
little high
we got a the lurker and and the Tom
Prison pimp Tom to prison pimple all
right so we've got some verticality here
you guys I can pull up my feet if we
need it but we'll see
Oh what is this
is it because of the zombie type thing
well where we going Rob I don't know
oh hi like the ping I can't ping good
luck to me I don't know this map let's
go Daryl you've really got to hold these
to pick up huh
whoo I got body armor level two let's go
zombozo up in this Rob there's armor on
me you need it ok I'm just picking yeah
I don't know how to play this game ok
got trauma kid I'm just gonna use that
right now we got a hold it heal 1 it's
like relearning some trouble huh yeah
there's one
I can't ping it's 1 in front of me
there's one to my left and look in the
house yeah
on town he's weak though he's weak oh he
knocked me out he's right next to Oh
down but not out
oh you can redeploy yeah I guess
everyone's learning from me effects I'll
try to take your stuff take pic my level
two armor take it take it I should I
should let kept that shotgun
uh is this season pass only I think so
I'll just take it oh I'm back I just
come back you don't even have to do
anything I come back what's happening
okay
I'm flying down to you okay come come
get this guy stuff I won't take it I
don't know oh oh those are birds there's
stuff here maybe we get for like four
more redeploys or something is that what
it is okay
something like that right follow you I'm
trying to clip some stuff here yes but I
guess we go what's the circle like here
we're kind of in the circle I don't know
why there's so much of it on the water
go have 22 bandages if that helps
that's cool let's go this way okay
following you that's a tree
let's go to this beam of light oh you
want to get some zombie action going
sure all right let's do it
good thing we're showing your feed I
died right away
oh yeah there's definitely some zombies
over there okay alright some PvE action
alright oh that's a zombie bunny oh I
hear footsteps to my right eye not me
yeah they're not you feels like there's
the circles closing the circle is
closing Oh connection interrupted behind
you I can't do anything I'm literally
lagged out I'm down no I literally got
lag fury jump I believe this is just
free up here right no I think this is
part of the deal see you know oh is it
what do I know I'm wrong I look like a
zombie oh you say one of our dudes is
nearest I know you could revive me that
I just saw
alright coming back in this is really
throwing me up try to come to you rob
yeah come revive me if I could actually
okay you just landed in the water huh
all right dude sure did oh here's only
hate this camera angle I can't look up
thank you gotcha how do you become a
zombie like when you come back so so I'm
out yeah oh do we use all our revives
I guess so no I guess I'm back wow we're
in it for the we're gonna to learn I I
don't know what's going on yeah I'm
putting that out I'm redeploying again
oh the drop is so hard I know I couldn't
control it really Oh watch out
nice plays nice plays oh this guy's got
like a triple barrel shotgun got the
blunder rat ooh
Rob I just got a pistol there oh now I'm
down I'm back though down but not out
I think our guy Tom the prison hey we
got some good tips top man top rate is
how many reasons again I just respond
and died I'm coming back again how many
how many do I possibly get it was like
oh wait okay so then what's the it's the
circle there so it's three we have three
more oh crap I guess just keep dropping
down here man
the action is frantic aleksander clever
lavalla what the hell is going on I
don't know man there's all these bags
this has been one of the weirdest
morning's of my life so much going on
oh yeah we're just getting all these
free easy kills cause I keep like
dropping on their buddies you know what
I mean yeah I guess about the blender
blender bat oh no I got you buddy
oh just once just got pistols okay
this right here my dude come to you all
right so we got to be out of them now
all right
and I got two left you got zero I got
zero gotcha
Oh gotcha is it the sweeper I'm back
yeah I don't I honestly don't I don't
get it but all right
now that's a cool little glider that's
fun I like that I have a pistol though
so I don't come back fighting with
nothing though so I think now I'm yeah I
think so
all right so there's like four logos at
the top right yeah you see that there's
four logos oh I really wish I could ping
him what is the is that the the broom
they're mean chat MGP says so confusing
yeah you got that right this a lot
meeting we're watching you teammates are
out I got a pistol
nice pop some heels we can can we lose
where we like top - oh we were bad
nice assists that makes sense that was
much but yeah like I'm sweeping up the
kill
okay that's why it I'm gonna leave bad
we got a second on our first try I yeah
I don't know you know we should have
probably looked up a little bit more
like what's going on but like I don't
like I don't care I don't understand why
you would have this many responds
without like you know the broom is a
wipe sick it's weird it's wacky I'm
digging it though weird wild wacky stuff
just gotta get used to it again go
through the sewers like in the rock okay
Wow there's some where's my where my
mods at man I'm about to I'm about to
lay some sweet justice yeah yep up
that's not the wrong person right person
that's my bad that won't work
there you go I need to get this guy back
though yeah whatever
sorry to plunker boy I didn't mean to
get rid of you all right try number two
we got second place first try without
even really knowing what the hell we
were truly doing so what's interesting
is like if you go down and you got a
bunch of good stuff you want to go back
to your your loot yeah but then everyone
just goes over there right I suppose I
just feel like starting off with pistols
is rough well they also you can also
kill someone this'll be good yeah no I
was for sure like you can hold your own
just like I can't kill get all the good
stuff you want it back use your words
properly Vic Damone asking what's better
between the three kind of big nan well
actually apex very important a career
down the block up here than firestorm is
what Kenneth sim has that's my room I
put blackout over fortnight of it I'm
just going straight down
I don't know sure yeah I don't know that
seems like a good point I see you I see
you I see you we're basically back over
we're just now okay so we have five of
the what looks like a respawn I hear
some zoms
yeah this is literally where we were
yeah just loot it all up they don't know
I don't know about this spot Rob oh gold
Hades I'll take that close above I think
yeah yeah I can't pay my location okay I
gotta get back with you you're upstairs
kill the one I just got down
oh no you're I'm falling orange you have
a different date on now you're good
you're down yeah he was upstairs I had a
cold Hades you want to try to grab that
okay so I have four more respawns is
what it looks like yeah I can mod do you
probably crimes I just gotta get seen to
ask a guy named Ryan Schubert
which I think I should
wouldn't suit me we lost a guy like
completely are you just gave up suppose
it's weird how the respawn like ramps up
I guess
like the time it takes to get back in
good like I feel like like later stages
of the circle maybe it's just quicker
I don't know we don't go inside those
people are just heartburn bad dude right
there that I can't thank for this guy
you guys chasing hi Rob hi guys I do let
me know if you see a gun there are TVs
in front of me like chasing our boy just
now their footsteps yep there's two guys
in front of me are you maybe gave no one
just you like sigh there's a guy in
front of me fighting
kind of ran off huh nope
God dang it it was bait oh now we're
dead dead huh replace eight maybe if
your whole team dies you're screwed so
our team has a select amount of revives
right is that how it goes down
that's one I'm gathering now we don't
have individual revives I think we use
them all up no I had four I'm saying I
like I should have had another I wasn't
paying attention to that counter but
that's what I'm gathering because I only
respond otherwise fun ways or once ya
wants me to we're learning figure it out
we're gonna get a dub we we got a second
so I feel pretty confident we'll get one
by the end of this just check the
blackout mode is free through April 30th
says crime that's cool
are people still playing pop G probably
but not as many maybe but like I think
there's I think was the more recently I
think Pope G's really big
internationally right that's not John
Luke that's Rob so Jonathan
yeah I'm wrong I got it I got to figure
this map out there's a lot of where's
the sewer we got to get in like the rock
yeah there's gotta be a sewer got to do
what Sean Connery would do what's crazy
is that like if you kill it down person
like that one melee is stronger than
like you shooting them yeah weird yeah I
know right compared to like hey pecs
maybe we just swim in the water here
they'll never know that's smart
that's a long con blackout battle right
game is just slowly turning into debt
normal deathmatch kind of I guess James
goons are asking if they're solo and duo
doesn't look like at the moment it just
it just looks like quads they're putting
people drop in at this reddit a house
they were I see you trying to wrap
someone's ex to me oh that's right you
unless you let's not you this one else
icon are you know your blue I got the
Bowie what's this it looks cool party
potential collapse detected relocation
to indicate it safe zone go in here all
new yep our favorite room yeah favorite
ok here
god this menu do you know what to do
Katzie
in there dude up Janice we buy this slow
okay top Sam is hungry sounds are so
distracting yeah I hear them way more
than I hear the good bad guys collapse
imminent get to safety Supply Drop
inbound
oh hey oh behind me I don't know I can't
hit you I don't know
[ __ ] I got down by you then I if there's
friendly fire that's kinda silly
oh this guy's where's he going
oh no they're trying to repair armor
though
I'm looking at zombies now I guess they
got here can't open the mystery box it
did I just hit you I think I could hit
advise further collapse expected
by this guy that you know I'm gonna come
to you I guess
that call supply drop incoming
nope
my circle collapse imminent get to
safety the boy just got taken out
what is even going on here so much
gunfire that's in here guys farming
something or there's guys up in this
house I'm gonna hit outside coming in
I further collapse expected travel to
indicate it's safe zone
what can I pick up his armor another guy
outside down the roof across
oh my god white people just landed
my circle collapse imminent get to say
faqatilu welcome to another guy in the
roof though down but not out get to the
lower lighthouse oh so you can't hit a
teammate blue hitmarkers okay I got you
this is kind of all right okay I can get
to you guys yeah you shouldn't shock the
shotty ammo you guys are still lower
level right
yeah we're just exact same area I mean
might as well just hanging out here
major instability detected he fact to
safe zone GD armor
my circle collapsed imminent get to
safety
I think it says respawns no more yeah oh
I hear a little baby crying up this one
here
circles guy up on the roof way in the
building
oh [ __ ] circle ow
oh it hurts oh I'm gonna die I think
down this circle hurts real bad I
believe in you rob yeah whoo we did it
you did it I did nothing
see I told you we got a W that was kind
of uneventful how many cousins you get I
had like six I think it was six keep it
keep
I guess I'll leave
I died to the circle it's so shameful
shouldn't have been looting I should
have been running should have been
running man
we got W that's how we did it we did it
I feel like my footage is a little
boring I mean we just camped out in that
house for a while it is what it is right
hey you take the W that last circle is
tiny someone was like heal heal heal I
like what you're right like it takes
away a lot of your health dude that last
circle was painful yeah I couldn't even
heal it with the meds Isis bamming it I
was running and spamming heal like
hoping for the best
mm-hmm are they killed I don't know
though like some of these kills kind of
feel dirty cuz they're like the reed
rafts and they don't have anything so
it's really about getting armor and like
it is a separate map it's a new map it's
a smaller condensed map there's only 40
people on the map there's redeploys
which is interesting I still I'll be
honest I still don't totally understand
how it exactly works so they got one
redeploy off and then those it's oh hey
we did it we got to win whatever it
takes to get a dub maybe you know like
Windsor wins exactly thank you rich
thank you cyborg man thank you for land
Rafi
mr. burns says rob was like what game is
this again that's kinda how I feel I've
been trying to ping this entire time I
know right I'm like there's a bad guy oh
wait let me tell you the coordinates
it's great yeah it's crazy I'm like I
want to spam that r1 stop shooting my
friend
oh here oh yeah blue markers yeah yeah I
hit you
although like you didn't die from Lila
right now when I redeploys per team yeah
so yeah so it is um I feel like we
didn't our team is not that much though
we did a good job we kind of like
nestled in that downstairs area yeah
oh where you going I try to follow you I
have the tip of this building right here
on top or below I thought there was a
door here that whatever that was that's
a zombie
how you looking Rob I'm upstairs in the
jail room get out get back is Nic Cage
an out the pen just be careful there's
dudes in around here just grab that
armor though yeah get that guy that's
the guy that guy mean hi Emma oh dude
our two boys are far rockets
you get back in you know here's my there
outside though I think circle collapse
imminent get this guy's armor level two
if you want you take level two you've
earned it I have
man just just pay attention to ammo
again it's like so difficult I did not
mean to pick that up
oh [ __ ] I need to heal okay so I'm gonna
take it he's got a vapor operator
just vapor oh I left the face were there
you should try to find like Armour bits
to repair your armor yeah this has a
knife on it on the same location we
could do something different if you want
oh my god I hate how quickly you pick up
a gun he just took my gun yeah I was
trying to reload
I don't know what's going on I just like
trying to like the pic guy coming down
up down the hall circle collapse
imminent get to safety like in front of
you yeah yeah you're looking out down
there you could have gone to the right
though
oh he's out the window oh oh another guy
Dan I was quick to the right that was
the dude yeah I got killed by the window
guy Christ you guys can do it
please I'm gonna bleed out all right
cool
and
I'm not gonna blow up if I touch these
oh look at look at the gone someone laid
a trap oh you had the drop on him it's
my stuff don't take my stuff don't fly
onto the roof that's a bad place to be
there's like four guys on the roof
oh yeah there's just a lot of fighting
on the roof try to get back to you guys
shot at nice circle collapse imminent
get to safety guy down the hall here
there's a whole map how precious died
yeah they're zombies are getting
stronger that's for sure I'm down I can
get me
I have no loot right now that that call
major instability detected safe zone
evac orders are in effect by some GD
armor
i sitrep circle collapse imminent get to
safety
[Music]
Nephi five six
guys to the right like 280 in this house
- laughs with the barricade
there's a guy running down
all right foot hi dammit we wanted
please stand down
yeah back dubs the auger is pretty nasty
oh where are you I'll pick you up there
you are
I don't know how to feel I don't know
how to feel either I'm just like there's
people there's people this circles
getting small it's like it doesn't feel
as fast in the beginning as you think it
would yeah for how close quarters it's
supposed to be and then this like last
circle is just like super frantic I
don't know it is I just feels like I'm
playing cod yeah like not even like a
Battle Royale
other than the fact that I had to pick
stuff up mm-hmm I don't sure yeah a
little merit report 5 kills what about
you probably like you probably have more
than that I feel like you're doing some
work for a while so nice the spit you
had the swordfish right is that what it
was oh yeah man I forgot like it is so
easy to like swap weapons yeah an
accident like yeah there should be like
a like a delay right like uh um should
take time to do that like you just so
instantly swap weapons and it's like oh
I forgot about that I guess
I think some of the the cooler random
weapons are from like the box from the
zombie box but I think you have to kill
enough zombies for it mmm dude up top
was a death trap I try to acquire enough
top and there's like two teams fighting
at least that's not I think the Shred is
what we've been doing which is kind of
like huddle up with four and kind of
chill in here yeah yeah you lute for
sure like on the people that don't have
anything yeah and like keeping keeping
your loadout the same as where we going
change I don't know the lighthouse
lighthouse right in front of it and go
back into the building again are we
going in the building or the lighthouse
building we go to lighthouse building oh
my god there are so there's on here
people here oh this guy's like potato
mode looking are you fighting just punch
them a jackhammer I'm out later get out
of there yeah you lose that was a
mistake should not have gone in there I
guess
what you just always go inside the
prison
yeah it's our home it's our home the
prison all
and on top and hope for the best
oh the top and
mountainous on in America look I got
with that start I think someone might
have to trick or something for the doors
to come to prayer that things that come
down no
got a fine damn you and I have a shotgun
I need up arm dude here level 3 RR n the
heck was that circle collapse imminent
get to safety
oh there's a rocket launcher on me do
you really want that thank you - I said
do you really want me no but I'm just
like oh crap there's a rocket launcher I
redeployed because I think you'd get X
amount of redeploys Supply Drop Inn
what just happened
hmm blew through my level 2 armor a
shotgun too strong yeah there's another
guy that has a gun I've got our buddy up
[ __ ]
yeah back oh crap there's so many people
on the roof here Oh another guy [ __ ]
come out oh I'm down I don't know how I
got here there might be another guy up
here yeah I didn't get me
oh I just got rocketed it sounds like a
grenade launcher oh I mean the circle
was coming
I'm down I know we won the last year oh
my god there's like so many people got
the full team here up we're out
damn no three in a row no three-peat all
right
oh we were out because her whole team
got wiped it wasn't head didn't have to
do with the response so it there you go
there you go
that's how it goes sometimes that's how
it goes it's kind of fun it's chaotic
it's super chaotic I like that when you
redeploy you do have a gun so you're not
like just fighting with your fists Oh
are there you go yeah but man you're
really out of it if you just have
pistols unless you're fighting another
pistol guy yeah I took one out but then
there was definitely another like I
think they slanted together as a squad
of like three or something but yeah I
got shredded in that one room by shotgun
and then he one shot me at that Rockland
I should have took the rock [ __ ] just
did it cuz I could have worse killed
myself I guess do you like this version
of blackout or the traditional blackout
and then I like the traditional I think
I do as well because if I wanted to play
something like this I just play like
malaria
you see that death mask for sure oh
here's the rocket were you at I wouldn't
fight been just crying my sister late
now but I'm inside the jail
I see you we can't get down huh
that was weird a bit earlier I feel like
someone opened these up
oh no there's no there's a space I lied
mama don't black out I feel good I feel
good about this round I feel like we're
gonna go back to our traditional spot
which is inside and we're just gonna
have to dominate the inside
prison or the warden you know you have
the warden I like that where you going
going up to the second level look around
okay
oh that was dumb saw me from the side
he's outside looking in
I should have the shotgun mistake
out front no freaking teammate just
shoot me up so you do take damage
oh yeah
oh you scared me this was me we got to
go
top-down yeah
-
you're dead right yep so hard to get
back on your feet
of coure is that you're out butts
we were wrecking not so much anymore
people getting smarter I had a level
three armor how big is a patch I don't
remember it took a little bit to
download though it's not going well
where'd you guys at same spot
I want a battle royale game where you
sail into the islands not skydive that's
not that's neat I like that
the circles coming in
Oh God like what do you do what's the
point okay to save someone why are we
here
okay first circle is not bad manageable
oh my god I hate this drop it's so hard
to steer what so hard to steer when
you're skydiving oh yeah I don't know
feels like you can keep redeploying so
maybe the last circle oh wow new for
life is just on an island by himself
yeah I going to new for life he's like
literally on a little island farmhouse
by himself
oh there's a bad guy here I'm gonna make
a sprint towards you then okay
ow ow ow inspected relocated to safe so
what is that this is nonstop rocketed
alright watch out there's someone yeah
I'm coming in where was your shooting
from dang it haha he's there somewhere
yeah it's probably their safety save me
a shotgun
turn guys coming down Oh God
leave me alone just give me a second
here guys don't shoot that was dumb
it's all up to new for life no no don't
engage okay oh man if you could have
just lived if only he could have lived
shouldn't have alluded in that situation
in the end there that's tough I was
looting too it's just like paranoid just
trying to find an armor you know like oh
but in that case you might as well just
yeah all right one more yeah one more
definitely one wire it's only been an
hour feel like we can get another W
hopefully I say that
Oh should we get Ben in here I don't
know he's even playing
give it a sec I'll just spam him no so
you can get paint cans from the the map
and then you can put that paint canned
stuff on your guns like grassy look the
grasslands the player count is 40 so far
there's only squads what is go or did
you send it to him give it a couple more
sex all right thanks everyone for tuning
in the game SWAT live we check out
various games sometimes games that we
have early for like preview purposes we
also check out content updates like
today for black out with the new
Alcatraz map kind of like a new mode in
a way and yeah a bunch of other stuff
games that are like recurring like apex
with new like season pass or new legends
also yeah just other fun various games
come check us out Monday to Friday 11:00
a.m. Pacific Standard Time it's telling
me it's not joinable go on without me
that's weird do we get anything good in
multiplayer you get those freak hands I
was just talking about all right here we
go
what do you want to go this is it I
don't know I have a hard time steering
you think they plan to do so I don't
know maybe
yeah it's hard to really come back in
off of the win seat drop but maybe they
did it on purpose
I don't know
Oh a little gondola cool all right feel
it feel it coming hello son
Oh slapping slappy
Ronna say you can get paint cans in
Alcatraz oh god I'm so sorry Rob I was
looking at Chad that was a mistake
thanks for made where did these stairs
go they go nowhere if you can get to me
there's like guns and stuff that's good
to hear
got my way i mighta fight you there's a
guy maybe behind me who this is all
right okay all right okay potential
collapse detected relocation to indicate
it's safe zone is advised
I Supply Drop inbound
you guys all downstairs I'm up someone
level up in the jail
I make my way to you dude still revival
huh I guess I'm trying to go get him Wow
I'll get about I'm down I'm right in
front of you oh really no no I died I
guess a red circle collapse him in and
get to safety
two bags oh I did not mean to switch no
I just took your time okay watch out for
the wires though here someone has been
playing a real trap type game where are
you going
use some power yes I'm fine this guy but
then that guy he's been dying to pawn
I've revived that guy's poise
actually weird that we haven't seen
oh dude our guy is doing it work be
advised further collapse expected
relocate to save alright so you don't
know we're all maybe the other side of
the island we're not sound like upstairs
killed our dude actually that side like
in here yeah that got killed both of our
needs
my god again high rap man I've seen
someone in a very long time
fix a red circle collapse I'm gonna get
to safety
that coal supply dropping comb is the
medic perk dude
I finished Twin Peaks or no I haven't
seen season three I watched season two
that was a weird ending so yeah like if
your whole squad goes down you're free
you can't respawn anymore which is what
just happened there which is unfortunate
we'll play one more but it's best to use
perks as soon as you get them yeah I
mean if we it's just so frantic you know
hard to remember to do everything that's
why I said like I personally think the
other the normal traditional blackout
mode like all that stuff makes sense you
have time to kind of like prep a little
bit here you don't know if someone's
just gonna roll up on you or not mm-hmm
all right we go last round
best round this is it get a Mozambique
yeah one day got two wins which is
pretty good I don't know it gets kind of
wonky at the end it's just like who can
outrun the circle and then like it just
gets some really super close quarters
and it's like who has better gear I
guess at that point but thank you all
for your tips appreciate it it's just
fun so far for the most part I think
there's some things that I prefer from
the like as mentioned the more
traditional blackout but you know it's
cool to have a change of pace for sure
happy that they it's kind of like a
different variation on
on their battle royale I guess I did not
even name for that well we have five for
our team let's go
and the one thing I will say is that
even though at least we're having to
wait here it's only a 30 second deploy
here we go
blackout
where we going Rob I don't know what
about like the tip yes but I don't know
roof roof all right I see you come paya
go inside to the jail hey good you got a
gun I took everything else no here you
loot up I'll go around
[Music]
oh we lost - dude can I not go through
sitrep potential collapse detected
relocation indicated safe zone is
advised
oh wait I know you just as a mom like
if I want Rockets Rob sitrep circle
collapse imminent get to safety
well there's a care package here
and get the dude at 190
1:59 you guys have a flamethrower chill
unless you can get them I kill the flame
guy Oh expected travel to indicate it
safe son pick up I would try to pick up
this way though
[Applause]
oh my god it's guys double team by
friggin pistols oh we're down and out
then huh because this guy's it sucks
this one's paid deals it's part of like
the season pass I would assume well I
think what crime said but I think
blackout in general is free for the
month of April all right I think I was
expected look I had a flamethrower I
know he burned me up too he barbecued me
I was weird there's like no action on
the in the inside yeah it's true this is
true everything this is their last game
now this is this will be yeah this is it
it's a one water stream yeah but for
real though this is this is it win lose
or draw
maybe we peaked already we peaked in
life with it back to back and now it's
just downhill from there
ring-ring I don't like being out in the
open hey we got doctor disrespect on our
team oh [ __ ]
I doubt it yeah hey someone go check so
that they can get up I want to see him
get salty when the guy
black out all right how can we lose it
we got the dock you think it's him I
don't I don't know actually I don't I
don't think so to be honest
we're going inside inside inside try to
land here where that near that second
floor oh there's people behind me I
might try out this rocket launcher
potential collapse detected advisory
location to indicate Oh double bolt gun
up near rob like I'm really gonna use
this palette in did you get someone yeah
give me one more there's another rocket
up here I want to ditch this thing it's
problematic
no I try to snipe that guy I hit him but
he didn't die that's the real doc so get
real nah I really shouldn't have tried
to snipe that guy though get to safety
Supply Drop inbound
come on he SPECT it's true man he's
expect that he's spectating me that's
what it's true he's the real one I guess
is how he's on on our stream anymore or
done I thought maybe he doesn't know
about the respawning hmm he lagged out
it's the real one damn he's lagging out
though what yet armor just try to chill
and move I guess or going ham I like it
[Applause]
[Applause]
my god
zombies real cool expected travel to
indicate it's safe zone well I just
killed a guy with armor with my pistol
that's pretty good
no come on dang it I died screwed up
I gotta go chill huh zombies eating
children
are you guys back in yeah I'm gonna try
to come to you
ow
there's our a rocket launcher in that
box
oh he just one shot me with a melee what
does the guy up top up top oh you're the
only one alive I'm back in okay it's a
nine seconds no I'm sorry what am i
again playing again I just asked you to
stay alive for 10 seconds a zombie
killed me I know that yeah we're gonna
try to get into that doc game again yeah
yeah we're good we're good we're good
we had something on one yeah I know and
I gotta eat food to see them you curse
me all right for real this is the last
ones
I was feeling it I guess that's a sign
of a good game if you want just keep
playing it or maybe cuz I'm just a salty
person in general know we can do one
more it's a one wash have you guys been
down the tunnels or the lock codes
combinations where I'm curious if they
made that area accessible and the
elevator I mean there's got to be
something because I feel like someone
was unlocking the doors because I
couldn't get back up top from the prison
cells but one match I was able to hmm so
I feel like there's definitely some
there's probably some Easter eggs and so
no doctor disrespect this time fortunate
does anyone in chat know if melee is one
one shot I don't think it is my guess is
what he did to me was oh I think we won
we won more than two right
did we win more than two yeah I know we
want to
all right here we go f t SS save my
shooting spot rocks like right right
over here
I'm gonna go inside right away and then
we're gonna loot that back room and and
then hopefully there's a box like there
was last time oh there was a gun up
there I should pick it up mistakes get
in the box is not here air footsteps
feels bad
freakin gonna be 40
who's got here pretty sure that was the
guy that killed me try to check out the
spiral staircase tunnels underneath the
cellblock try to look for it
oh no we still up here Rob yeah
someone's chasing me you see in that
small room he only has a pistol Hey it
moves good moves
good moves me too
you played that well played the corners
on that one dude art are other dudes got
level through your armor though I want
them to win at least one we won one
already we want to earlier
but it's not looking so hot right now in
all honesty and I don't even know if I
drop where we've been dropping that guys
might go there oh good lord
oh my god
imminent get to safety
well not going around the roof again oh
I see you hanging out hey it's our old
room though Hey look at that
hey Rob you can take this one right here
this that little sign on the wall oh
yeah yeah you can know I have that right
scared me again
Oh on the stairwell God not like this
the at level 3 armor on the stairwell
okay you guys go oh you died Oh what
don't know why I died instead there how
did this guy die Oh God okay you got
twin brother collapse expected travel to
indicate it safe so that's what sneaky
he looks like a zombie no I almost
didn't fire
[Music]
dang it
Oh is my last respawn I try to fight
some guys up top thousand mistake
i circle collapsed imminent get to
safety
need ammo I can fly drop inbound
further collapse expected which I'm
playing here we got a hammer and I got
my SMG and I got no one knows what I'm
rocking I mean I say we kind of hang low
for a little bit oh oh no it's not the
roof I don't know about I hate being
outside inside this building here know
where you are
I'm in this out and with you over your
shoe
thank you
nope damn surprised teamwork that's
gonna do it it's fun while it lasted
everyone that bad
pretty interesting mode I suppose if you
want to check that out you can it's
available for those who have I believe
the Battle Pass
thank you so much for tuning in me and
Rob greatly appreciate it thank you for
those asking giving us tips and all that
stuff we appreciate it
we did get two wins earlier and then
another no luck after that but I still
play it a little bit more try to figure
things out looks like there might be
some Easter Egg Easter so enjoy it if
you want to its out on ps4 first I think
just because of that time exclusive
stuff but come back tomorrow 11:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard time for games while
live we'll be playing some more fun
games as we always do when into Friday
hit that sub button if you haven't
last words Rob anything any anything you
want to say about Alcatraz
go back to the rock um yeah I don't know
I don't know if I'll ever go back to the
rock that's still there he's gonna go
back to Kings Canyon yeah yeah but yeah
stay tuned against off for more stuff
thank y'all have a good one puto
[Music]